Důležitost quantum computingu je zároveň podceňovaná
i přehnaně přeceňovaná.
I když quantum computing nenahradí konvenční počítače,
kvantová inovace představuje nové výpočetní paradigma.
Quantum počítače mohou spolupracovat se stávající výpočetní
infrastrukturou a řešit složité problémy, které byly dříve
považovány za nepraktické nebo nemožné.
To může změnit celé paradigma.
Například obtížnost rozkladu velkých čísel
na prvočísla je základem moderní
kryptografie. Pro velikost čísel používaných v moderním veřejném
a soukromém klíčovém šifrování by tento výpočet trval
nejrychlejšímu konvenčnímu počítači přes 300 bilionů let.
Pro velkokapacitní quantum počítač pracující
se Shorovým algoritmem by tento výpočet trval vteřiny.
Takto složité problémy existují ve všech odvětvích.
Potenciální aplikace quantum computingu
jsou obrovské.
Quantum počítače už teď rostou
a jsou stále výkonnější,
protože se snažíme zvládnout stále složitější problémy.
Od roku 2016 IBM zpřístupnilo quantum počítače
veřejnosti přes webovou stránku s grafickým rozhraním, které
vypadá jako notový zápis.
A také přes vývojářský kit Qiskit,
který uživatelům umožňuje programovat quantum počítače.
Vědci uvnitř i vně korporátního světa
provádějí experimenty
přes podobné portály. Zkoumají přístupy v chemii
a problémech strojového učení a snaží se přijít na to,
jaké otázky mohou klást
a jak je budou formulovat,
až technologie pokročí dál. Teď je ta
správná chvíle, aby se podnikoví lídři připravili
na quantum. Podmínky jsou připravené k experimentování
a rozšiřování této zásadně nové technologie.
Organizace, které se snaží být v čele
tohoto transformačního posunu,
získají konkurenční výhodu. Toto školení
tě připraví na zahájení tvé quantum cesty!